to minimize confusion because a lot of
you are trying to answer two questions
at once do not answer two questions at
once just focus on one task right before
from their finish that task and then
like segments and then move on that will
minimize the amount of light wait what
am I trying to work out which gradient
is up concavity down I'm sort of
confused right so have that first
derivative I'm just going to focus on
the second dude that's the first thing
I'm going to do you can see to go from
first to second derivative I have
noticed here are the spots where the
first derivative has turning points do
you notice that right so if I ignored
for a fact the second of this work this
was the first tribute in this assembly
if I just said there's a function
differentiate please you would say
stationary point stationary point the
derivative should be zero and zero you
content with that and the same way to
work out the rest of the picture I would
say no to me is this is the increasing
or decreasing its decreasing here it's
going down then it's a station everybody
it goes up and then it goes down again
right so these signs in here the signs
on one graph tell you about the regions
on the next 14 notebook for water okay
so i've got negative down here positive
here negative here are you content with
that so you can see I've got my parabola
shape coming through yup I'm gonna be a
little own a little rough and there's my
problem all right now I'm ready to climb
up the ladder gone down that will inform
me when I'm trying to work out from
County let's go up now you remember to
go downwards I said Tommy where these
stationary points are there going to be
zebras so to go to reverse I say tell me
where these zeros are can you see where
I'm pointing these zeros talking about
these stationary importance so therefore
to climb up the ladder i say told me
about these zeros there there are there
only two of them where you see those
zeros there will be stationary points
up here ok so there's one I already draw
a line through it because it was going
down as well but here's another one I
haven't done this one so this line goes
up I don't need to go down I've already
drawn the second derivative so up here
these two vertical lines should be
stationary points now the question is
what kinds of stationary points will
they be ok now for reasons that will
become clear in a second I'm going to do
this right hand side first ok the
derivative in fact I've even going to
write this just like I wrote over the
derivative is zero here what do I know
about the kind of stationary point
that's here and how do I know it any
takers it turns the reason I know it
turns is because the second derivative
is it's not zero it's negative right not
only do I know it turns I know which way
it turns the second driven to zero the
concavity is concave down so there's
going to be a maximum up here is that ok
so I'm going to draw myself a nice high
gish stationary points I'm going to
climb up to there now I look at the next
part and I say oh Lord I've got a zero
here there's a stationary point up here
and then I say well what kind of
stationary point do I have so I look to
the second derivative and the second
derivative is zero hug go back to your
flowchart that's not very useful in
itself right I need to know not just
that it's zero because sometimes you can
have a first degree of being zero and a
secondary to being zero and in the case
of y equals x to the 4 that's well it's
at any point just like this was ok so
what do I get out of this second
derivative to tell me what kind of
stationary point of God yeah it's it's
it's also it's a point
flexion as well yep and it's also
stationary point there's only a set of
points two points that can actually fit
that criteria very good so you can see
I've got it I've got the stationary
point the reason I know it's a point of
inflection is not because of the
secondary of being zero tell me what's
the definition of a point of inflection
a change in concavity and look it
changes you see or from negative to
positive concave down to concave up of
God point of inflection it's stationary
as well it's a horizontal point so I'd
like to draw my horizontal point of
inflection here okay remembering that
you I just said it's concave down to
concave are concave down to concave up I
know it's going to be concave down like
that and concave up like that you see
that and what I know about the first
derivative confirms that because look
the side here the first derivative is
positive that's why it's increasing up
here and then the first derivative is
still positive look at still climbing
increasing increasing you see it okay
now I'm ready to draw there's the
left-hand part to join these parts I'm
going to be a little bit messy but we'll
try like that you'll notice as well I
have my point of inflection there which
I got for a mum I got from here where
this second derivative also changes sign
and then I PR it goes back down so sorry
notice it's time to like camel right and
called the camel grass and by entering
let's just confirm that everything is
right let's imagine this was the
question and I've got to think about
gradient and concavity tell me
increasing or decreasing
increasingly increasing increasing what
happens three it stops for a second and
then it just keeps on increasing then it
stops and then everything it turns so
it's decreasing to those signs match the
region's here yes they do don't they
look positive positive positive positive
there it is and negative down here it
works let's quickly do concavity concave
up or down down down now transitions up
up up up transitions one more time down
down down down and you can see it works
right concave down the Secretary's
negative concave up the secondary
positive and it resumes being concave
down for the rest of it to me it works
ok last one now rather than leave you to
your own devices on this I will help you
through ok I'm help it through it's not
as hard as it easier so advice remember
one problem at a time one pop another
time so I'm going to go from this craft
down to the flooding ok I'm going to
work out the second derivative ok now
this is a bit tricky the first thing I
usually look for without going down when
I'm differentiating the first what's the
most important feature that you should
look for you look good you look for
stationary points stationary points here
give me zero is here right sorry my
things like that and I've got to say
that really important because people
confuse them they think 0 0 is here give
me 0 is your station playset you're
climbing the wrong way and
differentiating going down so i'm
looking for stationary points tell me
how many stationary points it sounds
none none it has that's what i meant to
say her head as this stationary point
now under the second like pen in hand ok
this thing never turns its gradient
never turns around it never stops either
is this left side over here is it
increasing or decreasing increase its
increasing which tells me the region
down here will be positive what at this
guy is this increasing or decreasing
it's also increasing so you can see the
region's when i differentiate down here
everything is going to be up here you're
over that